[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEITH DANEKIND: So
let's get started.
So I'm going to talk
about how to craft
a conversational API with
Dialogflow and Apigee Edge.
We're going to have
the Google Home Mini
talk to Apigee
Edge, which is going
to talk to a back end system.
Let me introduce my
co-presenting partner here.
What should we talk
about on today's webcast?
GOOGLE: We should talk
about how to build
a conversational
application and how
to use Apigee to connect it to
an existing enterprise system.
KEITH DANEKIND:
That sounds great.
GOOGLE: I'm happy I could help.
KEITH DANEKIND: Thank you.
GOOGLE: You are welcome.
KEITH DANEKIND: Goodbye.
So here's our agenda.
First, we're going
to talk about how
to build a conversational
application, what
is a conversational application,
and why is it interesting?
Next, we'll talk about how to
connect it to the back end.
So we have an existing
back end system,
and we're going to talk about
how we can adapt this and build
an experience API that's
specific to this device.
So it needs a specific
set of protocols.
How will we make that happen?
And then after that,
we'll follow up
with question and answer.
So what are conversational
applications
and why are they interesting?
So think of these as chatbots
and smart assistants.
So an example of
this is something
you might see on a
web page where you're
interacting with
customer service
or doing some predefined
tasks like that.
You might see this over
a messaging service also.
Also, think about
smart assistants--
things like Google
Assistant, Siri, Alexa--
things that you
would interact with.
Applications that run
within those devices
are also conversational
applications.
There's a great case for these.
So the case for conversational
applications is pretty strong.
80% of customer
interactions can be resolved
with a well-designed chatbot.
There's $65 billion of potential
salary savings from chatbots.
And 60% of consumers
want easier access
to self-service solutions
for customer service.
And 50% of enterprises
will be spending
more per annum on
bots and chatbots
than they would on traditional
mobile applications.
So interesting case
for these things.
Primary use cases
for this would be
things like
connecting businesses
with their customers.
So, how can you connect
a customer service agent?
How would you
control IoT devices?
And how can you connect
businesses to their employees?
We're going to run
into some challenges
when we try to build
one of these things.
A lot of the systems
that we've designed
are just not ready for this.
So let's look at those.
The first one is we need to
provide an intuitive user
experience using
natural language.
If you would have talked to a
chatbot just a few years ago,
you'd find the conversation
to be very restrictive.
If you followed
the script exactly,
you might get good results.
But if you wander at all,
it would get confused,
it would get lost,
and it would be
a very frustrating experience.
What we're going to see today is
this has changed dramatically.
Dialogflow, which
we'll talk about,
is going to provide a
very good and intuitive
conversational
experience for us.
So it'll be like
talking to a person.
And that's our goal.
This should be a
natural experience
that doesn't require the user
to adapt how they communicate.
We're going to connect that
new experience to an existing
enterprise system.
And that's a challenge.
When we built our original
enterprise systems,
we weren't thinking
about speaking to them.
We weren't thinking
about any kind
of conversational interface.
So we need to build
a whole facade on top
of that that facilitates this.
And then the third
part is, we need
to provide a great application
developer experience.
So we need an
infrastructure in place,
we need an API
program in place, that
makes it easy to create
new applications like this
for developers.
So how do we build
an application?
What are the parts
of this solution?
So first thing we're going to
talk about today is Dialogflow.
Dialogflow empowers developers
to build natural and rich
conversational experiences.
So you can talk with
Dialogflow, it will build up
a series of
conversations in there,
keep track of what
you're talking about.
And what we're
going to do in here,
we're going to have that send
an action over to Apigee Edge.
The second part in here is we're
going to talk to an existing
system to get information.
In the case of my
demonstration, we've
got a gym on the other side.
And you can ask the gym
when there are classes,
you want to sign up for a
particular class, things
like that.
That's a RESTful service
and it's existing.
But it doesn't speak
the right protocol.
So we'll see how to map that.
It also requires authentication.
You need a username and
password to get into this.
It uses a service
account for that.
So we need to work around that.
There's no traffic management
on this existing API.
So if we hook up a
million of these things
and they start
talking, we may run
into some scalability problems.
And finally, there's
no caching in place.
So we don't have anything to
allow this to perform and to be
able to handle the
kind of traffic
that we may get from
having new devices.
So we'll solve those problems.
Finally, we're going
to look at Apigee Edge.
And Apigee Edge is
what we're going
to use to adapt this
to the new interface.
So we'll build some policies
within Apigee Edge that
allow this device to
talk to the back end
and allow the back end to
respond in the right protocol
for the device.
So let's look at a demo.
And then I'll dive
in behind that
and we'll see how
we built the demo.
So back to the assistant.
Hey Google, talk to Demo Gym.
GOOGLE: Sure.
Here's the test
version of Demo Gym.
DEMO GYM: Hello.
I'm the Demo Gym application.
KEITH DANEKIND: What can you do?
DEMO GYM: You can ask me
which classes are available,
on a day when a
class is available,
and you can ask me to
sign you up for a class.
KEITH DANEKIND: What classes
are available on Friday?
DEMO GYM: Yoga, indoor
cycling, kickboxing
are available on Friday.
KEITH DANEKIND: When
is yoga offered?
DEMO GYM: Yoga is
available on Friday
at 9:00 AM, 11:00 AM, 6:00 PM.
KEITH DANEKIND: Sign me
up for the 11:00 AM class.
DEMO GYM: You're signed up for
yoga on Friday at 11:00 AM.
KEITH DANEKIND: Thank you.
DEMO GYM: You are welcome.
KEITH DANEKIND: Goodbye.
So what's behind that demo?
How did I make that happen?
How do we get it to talk?
So let's dive into
that and take a look.
So the first thing we used
in there was Dialogflow.
So the challenge
here is, how do we
build that
conversational front end
so that it can
respond to questions
and have answers and
keep track of what
people are doing in there?
So that's where
Dialogflow comes in.
So Dialogflow-- let
me go over here--
Dialogflow is where we're
going to build natural and rich
conversational experiences.
So this is going to
give us a new way
to interact and build products.
It's going to use
conversational AI on there
to make sure that we're
having a good conversation.
So what we build in
here can be deployed
to a number of different places.
We can deploy it to
the Google Assistant,
to Alexa, to Facebook
Messenger, on Slack,
other places like that.
So that's where
we're going to build
this rich conversational
experience.
So if you want to learn this,
take a look at dialogflow.com.
There's a blog on there.
There's some docs on there.
I worked through some tutorials
to get up to speed on this.
So if I wanted to build
something in here,
I'm going to click over
here on Go to Console.
From within there, I'm
put into this place
we're I'm going to
build an application.
So there's a few things
in here to talk about.
Intents are things that
we're going to say.
This is what we plan to do.
So which classes are
available on Friday?
I want to know which classes
are available on Friday.
That's my intention.
There's Entities.
Entities are things
that the system knows
about-- a particular date
or the name of a class
or something like that.
There's a number of
built-in system entities,
and then there are also custom
ones that you can define.
Fulfillment is where this
would go to be fulfilled.
In this case, it's going
to be a webhook that
calls out to Apigee Edge.
And then Integrations is
where we'll deploy this.
So that's going to be
the different devices
this can run on.
I'll dive into each
of these individually,
and we'll take a look at that.
So let's start with Intents.
So you heard me say, which
classes are available?
So within Intents, what
we're going to do is,
these are different things
that people would say.
We'll start with where
I started with this--
I give it a name.
Which Classes When
is what I chose
to call this particular intent.
And it has an input context
and it has an output context.
So the input
context is something
that would constrain
whether it's called or not.
A certain condition must
be met or Dialogflow
has to be in a particular
state before this
is allowed to be called.
In this case, this is one
of the first things that's
going to be asked,
so I haven't put
any kind of input
context in there
that would constrain
how this is called.
Because I want it to
be called immediately.
Next, down here I've
got an output state.
So after this has
been completed,
the state of the system is
"asked which classes when."
And this five over
here is the duration.
That's how long this
context will stay in memory.
There's also some parameters
associated with this,
like the date.
So when I say next Tuesday or on
Friday, it will remember that.
And it's going to keep that in
context, so that I don't have
to keep saying
Tuesday every time
I want to talk to the device.
The next thing to
look at in here
are these training phrases.
So what you do is you type in
a few examples of how somebody
might interact with this.
So, what classes are
offered tomorrow?
Tell me which classes
are offered tomorrow.
Which classes are
available today?
What classes are available
on Tuesday or Monday?
Things like that.
Which classes are
open on Monday?
These are all examples of ways
that people would say this.
Now, the great thing
here is this does not
have to be an exact match.
It's helpful if it's close, but
it doesn't have to be exact.
You'll notice that
some of these things
are highlighted in yellow.
Those are entities that
Dialogflow has spotted for me.
So this maps to a date.
This is going to be sysdate.
So when I say
tomorrow, it's going
to map that to a particular
calendar date for me
and it's going to put
that into a parameter.
So that's what the
yellow is in here.
The next thing down here
is Actions and Parameters.
So when somebody
asks this question,
I don't have the answer right
here in this particular spot.
I need to go call a system
and get this information.
When they ask what
classes are available,
I need to go do a query and
look up a list of classes,
find that, translate it
into the right format,
and then return
it to this system.
So what I've got in here
is, Find Which Classes
is the name of the action.
And then there's some
parameters that get sent over
to my webhook with that.
So I'd like to send the
date and the date original.
And the difference
between those two--
the date is a particular
calendar date and date original
is how they asked.
So if they said next
Tuesday or Friday,
that's the words that
they used for that.
And then if I can't get an
answer from an external system,
I want to have a
fallback in here.
And I'm going to
say, sorry, I was not
able to find which
classes are available
on that particular date.
So these are the parameters.
That's the action.
These are some responses
that would get called.
If you know the answer--
like if they say thank you,
you can say you're welcome,
right here with just this.
If it needs to call out
to an external system,
we're going to come down
here under Fulfillment
and we're going to
slide this slider.
It says Enable webhook
call for this intent.
And that means it's going
to call your webhook
and it's going to pass these
parameters and this action word
in a JSON body where
you can process it.
So that's one intent
that's in here.
A few others that
I have in here--
you can do things
like find class times.
Sorry, let's look
at another one here.
Let's find classes when.
So you can ask when a class
is, a particular class.
And then we can sign up
for a particular class--
Book a class.
Now, notice on this
one that there's
a constraint on the way in here.
There's a context that
has to be fulfilled
before we get into here.
So they have to have asked when
the classes are before they
can sign up for one.
That's just something I put
in here to demonstrate that.
So this context
has to be satisfied
before this will
even be considered
as an answer to something
somebody is asking.
And there are some
examples-- register me
for spinning on Tuesday,
register me for the yoga
class on Tuesday at 9:00 AM.
So there are a few different
ways they can talk to this.
These checkboxes
down here in Actions,
they mean that these
things are required.
So if they forget to
put those in there,
we want to prompt them.
So if they don't tell us what
the day is, for example, we're
going to say, on which day?
And we're going to
prompt them for that.
And then once we get the
answer, it will continue.
Similar to the last one, we're
going to pass a date, a time,
and we're going to pass a
class name in this case.
So those are the intents
that I have built into here.
Next thing to look
at are entities.
So the yellow ones in
here are built-in ones.
The purple in here, or
the pink in here, that
is a particular time.
Those are system ones.
These brownish ones over here,
these are different entities
that I've defined.
So it knows about regular system
things that typically pop up
in conversations.
But there are some
things that it
doesn't know about,
that you want
to define for your application.
So in my case, I have
names of classes,
like yoga and spinning
and cardio boxing
and things like that.
I need to tell it
about those things.
So I've come over
to Entities here,
and I've created a new
entity called A Class Name.
And that's going to
describe that class.
So within there, I'm
going to list these out.
These are different
ways somebody
might describe a class.
Kickboxing, yoga,
indoor cycling--
those are ways that they
might describe them.
You can also define
synonyms over here.
So someone might
describe kickboxing
as kickboxing or cardio boxing.
Indoor cycling might be indoor
cycling, spinning, or biking--
those are all different
ways they could do that.
And if we check
this box up here,
Allow automated expansion,
what that's going to do
is that's going to use
the AI and the speech APIs
in Google Cloud and
that's going to make it
so it will recognize these
other things that are also
similar to this that we didn't
necessarily list in here.
So that's how we enter
entities in here.
The next thing to look at
is Fulfillment in here.
So, how do we get an answer
when somebody asks a question?
When they ask what classes
are available on Friday,
how do we get an
answer for that?
So we're going to call
out to the webhook here,
and it's going to respond.
So within there,
we've got a URL.
This is Apigee
Edge in this case.
And that is my API
proxy that's going
to go and find answers for me.
I need to send in
an API key in order
to get validated by that
system and to identify
what this agent is.
So we're going to have
an API key in here
and that's going to be
passed in and that's
going to identify this system.
The other option in here is to
write the code right down here
in the inline editor.
So you can write Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
they can be hosted down there.
And you can run it
straight inline.
I'm interested in the
Apigee Edge application
here, because I'm integrating
with an existing system.
And I've got a great way to
map this request into that.
And finally, we've got
Integrations in here.
So this is where we would deploy
this once it's all written.
So you get it all up
and running and working,
then you deploy it on a
particular device or platform.
So in my case, I'm running
it on the Google Assistant.
That's the first option here.
We could run it inside a web
page, Facebook Messenger,
Slack, a few other
options in there.
So there's a lot of different
choices for where we
deploy this and how it works.
So what would I
do at this point?
I built these intents,
I've got some entities,
I've set up some
fulfillment, I've
got a few integrations
checked in there.
How do I test this out?
Well, it turns out there's
a nice testing harness right
in here.
And one nice thing
about this is this
is going to show us
the details of what
that body will be that's
sent over to the webhook.
So let's find out what classes
are available on Friday.
So I type that in there.
It's going to make a call out.
And it's going to get a context
back and an answer back.
So what we see here is,
I asked what classes
are available on Friday.
And it answered with,
yoga, indoor cycling,
kickboxing are
available on Friday.
And it also set a context--
asked which classes when.
And it sent this
over to Apigee Edge.
It processed it, it found
an answer, and it returned.
The way I figured out
what it was going to send
was I clicked down here
on Diagnostic Info.
And there's the
JSON body of what's
going to be sent over there.
So the interesting
parts of this are
we're going to see
within here query result,
we're going to see an action.
So the action was
find which classes.
And then the date down here
is an actual calendar date.
And then this is how
I spoke that date.
I said on Friday, I
didn't say 2018, 5, 11.
And then we can see
the response that
comes back from the system.
It's going to set
a context, and it's
going to return a few more
parameters at the bottom there.
[CLEARS THROAT] Excuse me.
So that's our basic information
that gets sent back and forth.
I use this to try and figure
out what I should send over
to Apigee Edge and how
to process it and things
like that.
So if we continue
our conversation,
we know which classes
are available,
let's find out when
yoga is offered.
Now, it remembers that the
first time I asked about Friday,
so I didn't have to
say Friday again.
I just said, when
is yoga offered?
And it says yoga is
available on Friday
at 9:00 AM, 11:00
AM, and 6:00 PM.
It's important in
these applications
to keep that
context, so somebody
doesn't have to keep asking the
same thing over and over again.
When we have a conversation
with another person,
this implied context
is in the conversation.
So if I say, hey, what's
available on Friday?
The next time I ask, let's
just assume that I'm still
talking about Friday.
So that date is stored
in the output context
from the first call, and
it's sent into the parameters
of the second call.
And again, we can look down
here at Diagnostic Info
and we can get an idea of
what's going to be sent over
to our webhook for fulfillment.
So here we are down here.
The action this time
is find class times.
The specific class name is yoga.
And here's the
two different ways
we specify the date-- the
calendar date and then
how I spoke that the first time.
And we see the answer that
comes back from the back end
system in there.
So that's our information.
That's how we're going
to work with Dialogflow.
Looks good here, you know?
It looks like this is
doing exactly what I want.
The next step would
be to figure out
how to map that to
a back end system.
And we'll dive into
how that works.
So at this point, you would
deploy it on an integration.
What I did was I set it
up on Google Assistant.
I can run it on my phone, I
can run it on the Google Home,
and it's going to
work in either case.
So the webhook
request and response
flow, the way to look at that--
I went and looked at the
reference documentation
on this to figure
out how to do this.
So go over to dialogflow.com,
look at the documentation,
click over to Reference,
scroll down to Webhook Request
and Response.
So here's the request
for the webhook.
It tells you what
that format is.
You've got to pass in a session,
a response ID, a query result.
I'm sorry, that's the--
yeah, in the request.
And then there's some
details under here
of what the object is.
And you can click
through on that
and it'll give you
all the details
on that particular thing.
On the response
side, we're going
to see that this
text comes back.
So we can have
text that's spoken
and we can also have text
that's shown on the screen.
So for some of
these integrations,
like if we're using
Slack or if we're
using the assistant on
a phone, for example,
we can return a series of cards
with possible answers on there.
We can return images,
URLs, things like that.
Or we can just have
fulfillment text,
if we're speaking to
a device, for example.
So that's our
request and response
and that's the reference
on how that works.
So the next tool to look
at is the existing service.
So we've got an existing
service in there
and we want to call
that existing service
and we want to have it
give us answers back.
So let's explore
what that looks like.
So here's our existing service.
What I've got here on
the screen is just a tool
that I use to call RESTful
services and get answers back.
So in this case, I've
got a URL up here
and my response
comes back over here.
So if I call my back
end system and it's
going to talk to
the classes API,
we're going to pass
in a particular date.
And with that date, we'll look
at what classes are available.
So we pass in this date and we
get back an answer that looks
like this.
And notice that's
a regular JSON.
That's just an array in
there that's coming back
with three different values.
That's not suitable to be read.
So there's that specific
webhook response we have to do.
And we map that over in Apigee.
So then I have two things to do.
I have to take the webhook
request that came in.
I've got to remap that into
a RESTful call that looks
like this with a date on there.
And then I've got to take
this response that comes back,
and I've got to remap
that into something that's
appropriate for the
device, so it can read,
it can have those contexts,
and things like that.
So similar to that, that
gives us a list of classes.
This is how we request the
times for a specific class.
So at the end of this URL
we have /classes/yoga.
It's going to return the
times when yoga is available.
If I want to
register for a class,
I'm going to do a post-operation
to /classes/yoga/students.
I'll pass in my
information and then
I'll get back a
confirmation number.
So those are the
three different calls
that we'd make to
the back end system.
So let's look at
how to map that.
So the next thing to
look at is Apigee Edge
and how we handle these webhook
requests and responses that
are coming in and coming out.
So I'm going to go
into Apigee Edge.
This is where I'm going to build
my API proxy to handle this.
And what I'm building
today, I would describe it
as an experience API.
A lot of times,
if you were going
to support a new
mobile application
and you've got an existing
enterprise system,
you would build an
application API just for that.
So this is an API
just to support
that mobile application.
And maybe it takes
all that data,
and it's going to shrink down
that payload a little bit
and make it something
that's appropriate
for a mobile device.
Think of this in the same way.
But instead of
mobile, this is going
to be a voice application.
So we're going to take
that existing response
and map it down to
something in here.
So let's look at
what that looks like.
I'm going to click on
API Proxies over here,
and we'll open up the proxy
that I built just for this.
So we've got Booking
Agent in here.
Now, if you noticed on my last
application, the URL's changed.
So there's going to be
something different on the URL,
depending on what type
of thing I'm doing.
There's /classes, /classes/yoga,
/classes/yoga/students,
things like that.
So I have a need
to change that URL.
So what I've done down here is
I've defined a back end target.
And within there, I've got a
little curly brace thing here
that says Action Suffix.
That's a variable that
I'm going to set in here.
I'm going to pull that out
of the webhook request that's
coming in.
And I'm going to map that to
the right URL for the back end.
And the way I've done that is to
put that on the end of the URL
here, as a variable that
will be satisfied in here.
Let's click over to Develop
and see what's in there.
So within Apigee
Edge, this is where
we would build our API proxy.
This is where I'm
going to do my mapping.
So a few things are
called on the request.
We'll see the
response come back.
That's what's
depicted over here.
I've got a number
of policies in here
that are going to manage
this request and response
flow for me.
And then down here,
I've got some actions.
I have a preflow which
is this stuff up here.
This gets called
every time, no matter
what's on the end of the URL.
So these are things that
I always want it to do.
The next three are
conditional things.
So I've defined one of these
for every action that's sent in.
So if somebody asks what classes
are available on Friday, well,
we'd find which classes.
That would be that one.
And I have one of
these for every action.
And then there's a
post-flow down here that
gets called unconditionally.
I don't have anything in there.
So for every time
somebody invokes this--
no matter what they put on the
end or no matter what they say
to it--
this will get invoked.
And then one of these will be
invoked conditionally based
on what's matched in there.
So let's dig into that in
just a little bit more detail.
So the first thing we want
to do when this is called
is I want to verify an API key.
When I set up my webhook in
there, I put in an API key.
It's passed as a header.
That will identify which
application is calling in
and which one's talking to me.
I want to keep track of that so
I can collect analytics on it.
And I also want to make sure
it's an authorized agent.
I might have different
traffic management policies
in here based on what
that application is
and what it's doing.
So by processing that API
key, I get a little bit
of security in there.
But I also get a lot of
rich metadata in there
about who the caller is.
I've put a spike
arrest policy in here.
So if I deploy this application
and it gets really popular--
maybe somebody runs a Super
Bowl ad or something--
I don't want a million of these
things talking to my back end
and crashing everything.
So this spike arrest is
there just to shut that down,
if too many of these
call in too quickly.
I'm going to remove
some headers.
So Dialogflow will send me
a very specific request.
It's got a bunch of headers in
there that are needed in here,
but the back end doesn't need
those, doesn't understand them,
and it's just not
appropriate to send them.
So what this code
in here will do
is, we're going
to set the content
type to Application JSON, which
is what my back end expects.
And then we're going to remove
a few different headers in there
that we just don't need.
So it'll take those
out of the requests
and reform the request.
The next one is get action.
So this is going to grab
that action from the webhook
request that's sent in.
So the webhook request,
within the body of that,
there's an action and
there's a session ID.
And those are two pieces
of information that I need.
We'll save the action.
So this is the analytics.
This is the statistics
collector in Apigee Edge.
What this is going to do is keep
track of what the actions are.
So I want to have a
report at some point,
and I want to have different
stats on who's calling what
and how popular these
different things are.
This next policy in here
is a key-value lookup.
So this is going
to be where we're
going to get the username
and password for the back end
system.
The back end system in this
case requires a service account.
It's got a username
and password.
We'll pull that out of an
encrypted key-value map.
And then this policy
will set the password,
so we can get authenticated
with the back end system.
So that's going to
happen with every call.
Let's look at the
first one in here
where we say Find Which Classes.
So in this case, they've
specified a date.
Which classes are
available on Friday?
We're going to grab
the date out of there
and we're going to
get the original date.
So date is the calendar
date and then date original
is the spoken date.
The reason I want to grab
this is when I put together
the response, I
want to tell them
which classes are available
on Friday and not 5, 15, 2018.
I want to speak back
to them the same way
that they ask the question.
So that's the
request side of this.
Down on the response side, I'm
going to get that response back
from--
let's look over here for
what that one looks like.
I'm going to get a response
back that looks like this.
So an array of classes in there.
And I need to translate that
into an appropriate webhook
response for Dialogflow.
So that's what's going
to happen down here
in this JavaScript policy.
So classes ToString.
So what this does
is this is just
going to iterate over
that array and turn it
into a string that looks
more like a spoken sentence.
And we'll set a variable in
there called Class String.
So if there's no
classes, set it to that.
Otherwise, just make it a
comma-separated sentence
and then return that.
And then finally we're going
to set the response in here.
So this is the kind of
response that we have
to send back to Dialogflow.
And within here, we're going
to have fulfillment text--
that's what it's going to speak.
And these curly
braces in here, that's
the evaluation of a variable.
So yoga, kickboxing, et cetera
are available on Thursday.
That's what that's going
to say when it goes back.
And then we need to set
that output context.
We need to put Dialogflow
into a particular state.
So that's what this does.
The way we do that is we send
back the session ID context.
And then this text
right here is whatever
that context should be.
And a time out for that, it's
going to last for five minutes.
If somebody stops talking to
the device for five minutes,
it'll reset itself.
And then we're going to
have a bunch of parameters
that we're going to pass back--
the date, the original date,
the list of classes,
things like that.
So that's this particular flow.
If we go to the next
one, we're going
to look at what happens
as that follow-up.
So they may ask--
they know which classes
are available on Friday,
but now they want to know when
is a specific class available.
So, when is yoga available?
So we're going to
grab out of here--
we're going to
parse that action.
We'll get that in the preflow.
And then we're also going
to grab the class name out
of here-- when is
yoga available?
And then the second one here is
going to grab the date and then
the original date.
And we'll store
those as variables.
And then we're going to
change the requests around.
I didn't talk about this
too much on the first one.
But I'm always getting a
post in here, an HTTP post.
And my back end
system is RESTful.
It expects a GET in there.
So I'm going to change
the verb to a GET.
I'm going to rebuild the URL by
setting a value for this Action
Suffix.
So that was on the
end of my target URL.
I'm going to put that
in there and that's
going to call the back end.
And then on this one, I'm going
to get back a list of times.
So I've got JavaScript in here
to map that array of times
into a sentence.
So it's going to
come back like this.
And then we've got to create
a string that looks like that.
And that's what this
code is doing in here--
we're building up a time string.
And then that's going to
be returned down here.
So down here we'll see that
it gets returned as a string.
So that's going to
be put into there.
Yoga is available
Tuesday at 3:00 PM.
That's what that will look like
when it's completely filled out
and sent back to the agent.
And then we're going
to set a context again.
This time the context is
Asked Find Class Times.
And then it's going to
last for five minutes.
And we're going
to send back which
class they were talking about,
so we can remember that--
a date and a date original.
Now, third step in here, they
want to register for a class.
So what does that
look like when they
go to register for a class?
First thing is, we need
to know which class.
So that's going to come
across in the context.
It'll be in the parameters
under that Action section.
So we're going to grab the
class name out of that body.
We're going to get the date and
we're going to get the time.
And then we're going to change
the request around again.
In this case, it
is a post, so we're
going to leave that alone.
But we've got to set the
payload to something different.
We're going to pass
in the information
about the user in there.
And that's going to
be used to register
for the class at
a particular time.
And then on the
response side, we're
going to get a
confirmation number.
The back end system will
return a confirmation number
for that registration.
We want to return that.
And then we're going to build
up the response in here,
like we did in the other flows.
So down here, you're signed
up for yoga, Friday at 3:00
PM or whatever they asked for.
And we're going to set a
context in here of Class Booked.
And then we're going to return
that confirmation number
in there.
So that's our three
conditional flows in here.
The way that I set this up
so that these would be called
is, within the preflow
here, the key part
here is this GET action.
So this is going
to be Agent Action,
and it's going to grab
that out of that JSON body
when it comes in.
And then if we look at,
down here in the code,
these three gray things over
here-- these three conditions--
these have a conditional
expression on them.
So if the agent action
is Register For Class,
then there's this flow in here.
And if the agent action is Find
Class Times, that's in here.
So that's how I set those up.
So let's look at this in
a little bit more detail.
Let's see what's
going on in here.
Let's click on the
Trace utility over here,
and let's start
up a trace session
and look at what this might look
like when somebody calls it.
So I'm going to talk into my
phone to set up this agent,
and we'll look at what it's
actually sending across.
Talk to Demo Gym.
GOOGLE: Sure, here's the
test version of Demo Gym.
DEMO GYM: Hello, I'm the
Demo Gym application.
KEITH DANEKIND: What classes
are available on Thursday?
DEMO GYM: Yoga, indoor
cycling, kickboxing
are available on Thursday.
KEITH DANEKIND: When is
kickboxing available?
DEMO GYM: Kickboxing is
available on Thursday
at 9:00 AM, 11:00 AM, 6:00 PM.
KEITH DANEKIND: Sign me
up for the 11:00 AM class.
DEMO GYM: You're signed
up for kickboxing
on Thursday at 11:00 AM.
KEITH DANEKIND: OK.
So there's our flow that's
going to happen in there.
And we'll see these different
things come into Apigee Edge.
This helps us debug
it, figure out
what was sent in the
request, the response.
I had this a little
bit off when I first
did it and it wasn't
responding the right way.
I looked in the Trace utility
in here, and I looked at it
and I realized that I'd
had a few things set wrong.
So we see these come in.
There's our evaluation of the
API key, the spike arrests,
so on and so forth.
Here's our requests coming in.
There's the actual body that it
sends and that sort of thing.
We can look at the
different stages in here.
We can see what's called
in there, what matched it,
which action was followed.
And here's the interesting part.
We'll see that this
was sent in as a post--
a v1 booking agent--
and then when it goes out,
completely different URL.
And now it's a GET and a
completely different URL
in there.
So we've dynamically
built up that URL.
We've completely changed
the request around.
And we're going to send
that to the back end.
And then when the
response comes back,
we'll see that we get an array
in here of these class names--
that's coming back.
Flow through the
JavaScript, we'll
see that the response
gets built up.
And then we got a completely
different response in there
that's coming back on this
side, that's formatted
in a very different way.
So pop through the
different things in here
and get an idea of what's
flowing back and forth
between here and how
that's going to map
into your enterprise system.
So that's a look
at our demo today.
The next thing to
look at, if this
was interesting to you,
you might be thinking,
how do I get started with this?
How can I start to build
these sort of things?
So what I did to get
started on this--
I hadn't used Dialogflow before.
I'd heard about it.
I thought it was pretty cool.
I thought I'd go check it out.
So I went out and I
read the documentation
and I worked through
the tutorial.
So there's a tutorial
out there where you build
a pretty simple application.
That got me 90%
of the way there.
I worked through that
and then I referenced
the docs a little bit.
But I'd say about two
days to learn this.
And it was pretty easy to do.
The next thing to do,
definitely visit apigee.com.
So on Apigee, you're going
to find all the information
about Apigee Edge.
If you're trying to talk
to an existing system,
I think it's the best way to
map that and make that happen.
Tons of information out there,
references, and documentation
on how to do that.
You can sign up for a free
trial, that sort of thing.
Community.apigee.com
is a great resource
for learning more about Apigee.
There's tutorials on
there, and then there's
a bunch of people who can help
you out when you're stuck.
If you want to learn
more about Apigee,
sign up for a free trial.
There is, on the
Apigee web page,
you'll see a big red button
that lets you sign up
for a free trial account.
Unlimited access-- it'll spin
up a cloud account for you.
Apigee also offers
hands-on enablement.
So if you want to
learn more about how
I did what I did in Apigee Edge,
you can sign up for an API Jam.
This is a class that we have.
It's a hands-on
lab, so you can work
through some tutorials
with our experts
and they'll help you out.
There's more of these
product demo webinars.
We do these all the
time-- a great way
to learn about different
things and interesting topics
on Apigee.
So at this point, we're going
to pause for some questions.
We'll be back in
just a few minutes.
OK, so it looks like
we got a few questions.
Let me go through these
and I will answer them.
So what happens if
someone asks something
that the agent can't answer?
So, great question.
This happens all the time.
What do you do when somebody
goes outside the boundaries
of your application?
So you can put some
fallbacks in there--
I don't know how to
answer that or that's
not something I know how to do.
You can also have
some hooks in there
like, I'd like to
talk to a human,
I'd like to talk to a
representative, things
like that.
And that can change the flow.
That could call the webhook
and take whatever action
you need to.
That could send it
on to somebody else.
It could send them
over to a web page
or wherever you want to do.
How do I get up
to speed on this?
So I built some applications.
That's the best way to do it.
Get hands-on with it.
You can read about it, but
you don't really experience it
until you're in there.
So go into Dialogflow, look at
that diagnostic information.
That's going to show what the
body is flowing back and forth
and things like that.
That was very helpful for me.
I made a few mistakes in here.
I didn't really understand
how context worked in here.
So for context
specifically, there's
a really nice blog entry
out on the Dialogflow blog
page that will give you some
details on how context works.
After I read that, I
understood how it worked.
Can you change the device voice?
So can we change the
voice of this thing
and how it speaks to us?
Yes, you can.
So there's a few different
voices that are available.
And you can switch
between those.
It's a nice thing to do for
usability, because then you
know that you're talking
to one application
or another application.
Next question, can this
be integrated with Slack?
So, yes, you can
integrate it with Slack.
So you've got a few more
capabilities in there.
What you saw today was strictly
a voice-based demo in here,
where I'm speaking
back and forth.
When you're in Slack, you can
return more custom context
in there.
You can return
URLs, you can return
pictures, things like that.
So look under the Integration
sections in Dialogflow
and there are some
details in there.
Also in the
documentation, it talks
about features that are specific
to some of those platforms.
So you can return
custom things for that.
You can have multiple responses
in your webhook response
and they can be custom, like
you have one for the assistant
and one for Slack and you
can return different things.
The next question is, can
you integrate Google Calendar
with Apigee Edge?
So, yes.
Google Calendar has a great API.
And Apigee is your tool
for working with APIs.
So look at the documentation
for Google Calendar.
You'll find that there's
some very nice APIs in there.
You can build a
facade in Apigee Edge.
Apigee Edge can handle
that login for you
and things like that.
So that's all the
questions we have today.
And with that, I'm going
to say thank you very
much for attending the webinar.
[MUSIC PLAYING]